so if you multiply a positive number
times a positive number you get a
positive that's what you're used to from
way back when you multiply a negative
number times a negative number you get a
positive number and if one of the
numbers is negative and ones positive
whether it's the positive one first and
the negative one second or vice versa
when one is negative and ones positive
and you're multiplying you get a
negative number now the nice thing about
multiplying and dividing okay is that
the rules are the same so if you divide
a positive by a positive you get a
positive okay if you divide a negative
and a positive you get a negative and if
you divide a negative by a negative you
get a positive so you can group these
rules together so there's not that much
to memorize or remember this one you
already know from way back to negatives
give you a positive and then ones
positive ones negative you get a
negative you don't want to confuse the
rules with adding and subtracting with
the multiplying and dividing they're two
different types of rules but here we're
gonna do some examples and I'll show you
so if you have a negative two times a
negative three we have two negatives
multiplied together so that's going to
give us a positive six you just multiply
the numbers and determine the sign here
we've got a positive 5 times a negative
seven
five times seven is thirty-five but once
positive ones negative that's a negative
35 so for example you wanted to spend
seven dollars on you know a notebook
let's say okay and you wanted to buy
five of them that's five times seven you
spent thirty five dollars so that's one
example okay here we've got a negative
144 divided by 12 144 divided by 12 we
know is 12 but a negative divided by a
positive is a negative okay this one
here are negative 32 divided by negative
eight so 32 divided by 8 is 4 negative
divided by another negative would be a
positive so this is positive 4 ok now
this last example is a little bit
trickier we've got a whole group of
numbers here multiplied together we've
got a negative 2 times negative 1 which
is positive 2 we have 2 times negative 1
which is
negative two we have negative two times
negative one which is going to give us
positive 2 positive 2 times negative 1
is negative 2 and negative 2 times
negative 1 is positive 2 so the final
result is positive 2 that was a lot of
work but we could have made it a little
bit easier if you have an even number of
negatives so for every 2 negatives you
get a positive positive positive and a
positive times a positive times a
positive is a positive so if you have an
even number of negatives 2 4 6 negatives
if it's even you're going to get a
positive if we added one more negative
on here a negative times this positive
number would be a negative so if you
have an odd number of negatives it'll be
negative if you have an even number of
negatives it's going to be positive when
you're multiplying or dividing so this
has been how to work with positive and
negative numbers when you're multiplying
and dividing just remember the rules
here and you've got it I'll see you in
the next video